winter is coming winter is coming winter
is coming the wait is finally over a
game of Thrones book is coming this year
nope sorry it's not the winds of winter
a Song of Ice and Fire celebrates 20
years of age with an illustrated edition
let's compare the book to it's HBO
counterpart when we last saw King's
Landing it was not the most peaceful
place in fact Cersei destroyed a large
portion of the city that was once worthy
of your favorite Instagram filter here's
proof a beautiful look at the red key
the iconic iron throne made from a
thousand twisted swords is seen
throughout the show but it's not exactly
like Martin intended he wanted it to be
10 to 16 feet tall with steps reaching
to the very top Congrats on making this
throne look even more uncomfortable
remember when Ned caught Arya with her
sword after a quick heart-to-heart
conversation he let her keep needle here
it is in black and white
notice how young all the children look
in these illustrations as compared to
their HBO counterparts on her wedding
day Daenerys was given a beautiful white
horse some useful reading materials a
crate full of snakes weird and the
infamous dragon eggs the eventual mother
of dragons sits here on her throne
surrounded by the many gifts she's
received crown for King well that
honeymoon was cut short Drogo had enough
of his new brother-in-law and gifts him
with a crown of gold not the crown of
gold you want here it is again in black
and white for your viewing pleasure
back at King's Landing Ned Stark is
executed in front of his daughters
Joffrey's evil translates perfectly from
TV to this illustration and full-color
check out that smug look on his face as
if killing him wasn't enough Joffrey for
Sansa to look at her dead father's head
on a stake he's that evil The Hound
stopped her from pushing Joffrey off the
bridge and wiped her bloody face on pen
and paper The Hound looks a whole lot
less intimidating everybody's favorite
character and doorstopper carried the
time-traveling mind-controlling
and tree hugging bran stark miles and
miles across Westeros
he's immortalized in this piece with a
much younger brand on his back finally
let's end with life or a lack thereof
beyond the wall how the hell will the
night's king and his army of White
Walkers be stopped all we know is these
bad guys are headed south and love a
good Westeros winter
something tells me a lot more people are
gonna die so what are you waiting for go
pre-order this book immediately it's
going to be a long winter we have quite
some time until season 7 premieres
remember for all things Westeros and
Beyond stay right here on gamespot
universe winter is here
[Music]